my name is Luna Rock and from below cook
talk Northwest Territories I'm an artist
print maker the images I like to work on
our annuit way of life in a traditional
way of life
camping scenes landscapes and people
animals dog teams our third culture it's
it's dying
it's slowly dying and within the next 20
years who knows what will happen and we
are trying to keep our culture alive
through our art when the times changed a
lot of younger people they're going with
the changes a lot and they don't know
how their ancestors used to live so by
doing that on on art then you know it'll
give a little bit of sense to the
younger generation I've been doing this
for about 30 years I like it I love it
it it's a lot of work it takes a lot of
patience you know learning how to do art
won't happen overnight it takes years
years of practice printmaking was in
business for almost 40 years before its
closure and we just want to get it up
and running again like it was in the
past
it's I'm hoping that it's not a dying
art so fully weak once we get a print
collection going it'll be yeah produce
year after year it should never have
died off in a first place